how do you know another actor that
you're working with is good or is is
giving you something back is in the
moment with you well I mean you some
actress you definitely feel it feel it
more than you do with other actors but
it's not my job to judge anyone it's my
job to it's my job to work with them and
I'm just gonna listen and I'm just gonna
and I'm just gonna believe what they
tell me but yeah I mean definitely when
you work with someone really strong and
you feel it that's really nice to have
it's definitely nice work with people
who are really dedicated to what they're
doing but it's not my job to judge
anyone oh it's my job to work with them
so it sounds like it's almost um it's I
think this just sounds like so like new
age or whatever it's like it's like
something you're feeling almost like in
the pit of your stomach with the other
person that they're present for you yeah
Robbie no you put your attention on the
other person you look them in the eyes
and you listen and sometimes you know
you're gonna feel more with a certain
actor than you can feel with another
actor but I mean I'm not gonna sit there
and judge anyone went because then I'm
not in the moment and then if i'm not in
the moment then how are they gonna
listen to me and then get the best
performance out of them I you get the
acting should be selfless it's about
what they're talking about it's not
about you so I think that you know just
you just gotta remind yourself to like
you know there are times I mean you're a
human being there times that you're
going to kind of pop out or whatever of
concentration and you just got to put
your you know again put your focus on
them and recenter yourself and you know
whatever happens happens spontaneity
like this dog the kids were my so cute I
would you see the song hopefully I'm not
thinking about my lines or performance
at all in a perfect world I I don't know
I tried to prepare a lot I and just kind
of let it rip you know I have a point of
view i'm prepared i know what i'm saying
i know why i'm saying and I know
everything I'm saying and why and
everything you know is understood and
everything's understood i'm not really
necessarily thinking about it but then
if I do find myself thinking about it
then the next tape of take I'm like okay
recenter look at the person listen to
them and just kind of let it go and you
know there's times that are going to be
easier than other times and uh you're
human and things are going to come in
and out it's not like you can just a
hundred percent always be in it but but
you know you try your best to just focus
on the other person
you